Hey everyone, it's Michael Boss and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Monday, May 22nd, 2017.
Now, it was an interesting day uh big
update again in the S&P. So, you know,
we're coming back on a lot
of, you know, the loss that we had on
Wednesday. Now, again, I'm recording
this. It's about uh just before 900 p.m.
on Monday night. There was the bombing
um in London, not London in Manchester
rather at the area Anna Grande concert
and you know in case you're wondering
what the market did off that it it sold
off but not much. Um I mean it's it's a
sad state that we're in when you know
you got a bomb goes off in in a major
city. you know, the Manchester Arena in
Manchester is is the largest indoor
arena in in Europe and, you know, S&Ps,
you know, before it went, you know,
before reports started coming in, we
were trading in the '9s, you know, low,
you know, high 89s and we we sold off
down to um, you know, 20 86 and
3/4. And, you know, that that's not much
of a reaction. If you're looking at the
bonds, you know, usually you get um, you
know, some sort of bombing. You'd see a
flight to quality generally and you're
not seeing, you know, pretty much
anything happen and the markets aren't
really reacting. That's a sad state that
we're in nowadays
is I hate to say it, you know, but these
um, these events, these bombings are
becoming
like part of life. You know, you just
got to accept it. That's scary. That's
scary. You know, honestly, if if this
was, you know, 10 years ago, 15 years
ago, and, you know, something like this
happened, you'd see the market down 10
points. You know, you'd see bonds
rallying, you know, full bond points.
But, you know, now you're not seeing
pretty much anything. You know, we got a
little bit more action in the overnight
session than you did all day in the
um in the main session in in the bonds.
I mean bonds were doing nothing
yesterday. I mean literally nothing. You
know you got your normal distribution
day there. I mean even when I say that
it's extremely small very tight range
very light volume.
But you know it's just a very quiet
quiet day in the in the bond market
yesterday. But you know before I jump in
I I should really go through the brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purpose only.
should not be considered a listation to
buy or sell a futures contract or make
any other type of investment decision.
Futures trade contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor. An
investor could potentially lose only or
more than initial investment. Risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle. Only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading. Past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results. Now again,
you know, I I I say this I put this
disclaimer up there because, you know,
partly the reason I put that up there is
because I want to deter people that
thinking, you know, trading is easy.
Trading is is hard work. And, you know,
there are a lot of people that thinking,
you know, I'm going to learn day trading
like you could just pick up a book, you
know, that you that you buy at uh the
bookstore for $19 and you become an
expert trader. No, of course not. you
know, just as you know, you can't just
pick pick up a book on medicine and all
of a sudden, you know, start curing
people or performing surgeries. Of
course not. Um, it just doesn't happen.
But anyway, you know, now that I got
that through and hopefully I've
dissuaded a few people um that aren't
really serious about trading, um, you
know, let's go in. There's some very
interesting things in the market. We'll
start with the British
pound this morning. Excuse me. So, I got
this damn cough.
Next week, I don't know if I'll be doing
these recordings. It's uh Memorial Day
weekend coming up and I do have some
plans. Um I'm overseas though, but I
still got plans even though it's
Memorial Day. It's uh the British pound
this morning. You know, let's look at
seven. You know, people say, "Well,
you're starting at seven because you had
some losing trades." No, you know, I did
a nice
um ratio here with the point of control
at the t the swing high and the delta
scalper giving a nice sell. You know, it
was a nice it was a nice move. You know,
you went from the uh 1320 area down to
130. Even price rejector is giving you a
buy here. You do rally back up, but I'm
I'm more interested in this high. You
get up here near the high of the
day.
And you have a couple things. One, at
this high, you have the delta sculper
kicking in. You have the price rejector
also giving a sell. You don't have a
ratio. You're uh two ticks off the high.
You know, this is a rare case where the
Delta surge came before the Delta
Scalper. This is Delta surge. This is
Delta Scalper. Usually, it's other way
around, but in this case, it's right up
here. Um, and you do you sell off again
from the 30, you know, well, this this
bar here actually in the 24s down to,
you know, down to 10 that area. You do
have the delta scalper giving you a buy
here. Now, again, you know, when I say,
you know, you have this delta sc really,
all it does is it reads delta. I don't
want to get into the analysis of the
delta every single time the delta is
giving me a sign with the delta sculper.
That's why I created the delta scalper
to
basically take that effort off of me,
you know, that analysis off of me and
and just sort of free up my brain for
other things because, you know, when
you're looking at chart, an orderflow
chart or any type of chart for that
matter, you know, there's a lot of stuff
going on, right? And sometimes, you
know, you're looking at one market and
something's happening in another market
and you not quick to pick it up because,
you know, it may take you 15 seconds to
do the analysis, but you're sort of
focused on one market. You know, you're
maybe you got a position on there and
that one requires more of your
attention, but you know, out of the
corner of your eye on another monitor,
you start seeing something flash. You
got the Delta Scalp or the Delta Surge
or, you know, any of these other Delta
tools or orderflow tools. you know, it
just gives you it's like having a
trading assistant, you know, I don't
know how else to describe it. It's like
having someone do the analysis for you.
Um, in this case, it's the computer,
right? It's just reading the delta, the
order flow, you know, and then take into
account a few other things and, you
know, giving you that sign that, hey,
you know, you have a potential buy. You
know, you still got to pull the trigger
as a trader. Um, you know, it doesn't
take it that away from you. But, you
know, really what these are are tools.
You know, I I like and I like to say,
you know, these are like the slap you
upside the head dummy indicators like,
"Hey, don't miss this." You know,
because, you know, you do have, you
know, most traders, most day traders do
monitor more than one market. You know,
even I see these pictures of guys
watching domes. They'll have 20 domes
open up on there. But are they really
watching 20 domes? No, of course not.
They're concentrating on one, but
they're constantly scanning. Right? Now,
imagine if you had a tool that can
highlight to you when something's
happening in a different market. You
know, you don't have to, you know, twirl
your head around looking at, you know,
20 different screens or 20 different um
what you call it, 20 different uh charts
or domes. So, anyway, we do rally. We
got we go up from, you know, 130 even
where you have the buy there. You get
all the way up to the into the um 50s.
Actually, you come off. There's there's
nothing in the order flow other than the
divergence up here. I would have liked
to get the ratio up here because this
was would have been a nice sell to take,
but um it didn't show up and then we
just sort of, you know, drifted off into
the close for, you know, from 10:30 all
the way up until 3:00 in in essentially
a very tight range. I showed you the
bonds. It was it was kind of it was a
very tight range in the bonds. I showed
you that earlier. Now I'll show you the
five years. five
years, you know, as as well in a kind of
tight
range as well this morning. Um, you
know, it's going from seven this area
here. You have the delta surge giving a
buy here, but you know, it's a very
tight range. You get up to this high,
it's a ratio. Sorry, it's a divergence.
There's no ratio. You go sideways, you
start getting some align PC's, start
rallying up, you get another divergence
up here. No ratio. This one's kind of
close though. This one's closer. Um,
it's 085. I like 7. you do sell off, but
a very uneventful day. Um, again, you
know, what's happening right now in the
evening session, you could see we've
gone up a bit. Um, you know, as as news
came out about the bombing in in
Manchester, but then you just drifted
back. Oh, okay. You know, I mean, I
don't know. Um, you know, reading
reports that it was a suicide bomber and
stuff, but it's at the point now, you
know, people unfortunately
um I don't want to say don't care, but
you are getting used to it. That's
scary. It's the world we live in
nowadays. So anyway,
um let's look at the Japanese. Yeah, you
do have the delta scalper giving a buy
there, but I could talk about it. There
was one thing more interesting up here.
Up here you got the
high, you have a divergence. Okay, this
divergence worked, you know, a naked
divergence. Here you got the delta
sculper given the sell. So you know you
know things are changing here up in this
at this high of the day with with the
delta with selling taking over and you
know you're seeing a shift from you know
buying to selling. You see all this move
up here all positive delta. Now all of a
sudden you see this move lower all
negative delta but really the sign that
it was changing was up in here right
with the delta sculper giving you that
that sign. Now you come down here, boom,
boom, you get
the trap traders sell, then immediately
follows with the trap traders buy. That
sucks. You know, sometimes it happens.
You know, I said, you know, you could
only trade what the market gives you and
then it's given it to you right there.
Um, it's unfortunate that it was one
right after the other. Usually it's not
one right after the other. You know, I
said sometimes it doesn't happen and
then sometimes you get twice a day. Now
you know the other thing is you know I
have this filter for the
um balance uh the volume threshold on
the imbalances set to to one actually
normally have it kept at 50. Now you
know what difference does that make?
Well if I have it set at 50 this one
will show up. This one against 50 will
show up. This five against 22 won't show
up. Now is that important? Well, it is
because, you know, if you want to filter
out not strong imbalances, I mean, you
know, is 5 against 22 strong? Yeah,
maybe. I mean, you might consider it.
But is zero against nine? No. Two
against 10? No. One against five here?
Not really. You know, those are not
strong. But, you know, in this case, you
know, currencies, I like to see them all
and then make my decision. Five against
22. Yeah, it's borderline, honestly. Um,
one against 50 definitely. But you know,
like one against five, no. Um, zero
against five, no. But you know, you
know, one against seven, no, of course
not. But, you know, I like to see them
all on currencies. Now, if you said, you
know, if you had set it at 50, this
would not, this one would not show up
and this one would and it would look
terrific, you know. But again, I I'm
showing it how it looks with everything.
So, you know, people don't say, well,
you know, you're filtering it. Well, in
this case, I'm not. And sometimes that's
what you get. But even if you took this
trade, you took the loss, you came right
back, took the next trade, which is this
one. You got everything back and then
some. Then you get up here, you get that
new high, you got the delta scalper
giving a sell again. You got the
divergence. Okay, but no ratio. You do
sell off a little bit. Um, come up here,
make new
highs.
Now, this what I'm talking about. You
know, you got the arrow there, but you
know, imbalance is one. So, it's not an
accurate. You know, you got very thin
volume up there and it's sort of giving
you this sign. If if I had the imbalance
volume threshold set at 50 or above,
this arrow will definitely would not
show because it'd be, you know, one of
the requirements is the imbalance and,
you know, the other stuff. But it's it's
just not
happening in there. I mean, it's
appearing because, you know, I I have
the imbalance set at at the lowest
volume threshold. That's why it's it's
taking all this stuff into account. And
then um 9:45 we do rally. We get up to
new highs. Price rejector here, price
rejector
there. You don't have a divergence. You
do have the U-turn giving you a sell
there. Um you start coming down. You get
a delta sculper buy, but it's on a red
bar, so you're not interested in that.
Here you have the trap traders again,
and you get a nice little move up. But
then you get here you've gotten the uh
delta scalper giving you the sell and
you see you you just basically come off
down into the lows of the day. Um you
get this buy signal here but you just go
sideways. Now S&PS the 10 range even
though S&Ps were up a lot today. Um 10
range honestly didn't really give much
in terms of trading
um what you want to call it trading
clues.
you know, it's kind of a tight range
most of the morning and cash open. We
just sort of worked our way up and we're
putting in these bars with, you know,
this bar here. You put in 139,000
contracts, which is a lot for a 10-
range chart. Um, you started coming off
of this high, you got the ratio down
here, then you start rallying up, you
starting seeing multiple buying
imbalances, which on a 10 range bar, you
know, even though you don't have a
stacked imbalance, if you've got
multiple imbalances in that bar, it's
still quite effective. I mean, you can
see You know, here you got two. Here you
got two. Here you got two. On the way
up, right? Which is what you want to
see. Here on the way down you got two.
Back on the way up three. And you go
next bar
up another three. You hit this high. You
got a
divergence. This was interesting. Again,
you know, this is a bar you put in
decent volume. Um, where am I here? I'm
confused. uh on this bar here you had
negative
delta
4,000 positive max delta
um 5,000. So, you know, you did get
there. You had some very strong buying.
Then it came and it changed and it sold
off a little bit, but then buying came
right back. You know, very little
selling in this bar. And this one, you
know, again, we put in some decent
volume. You know, once you start getting
up into above 80,000, it's usually
considered already for me, at least
considered heavy volume for the bar. And
you know, each of these bars, you know,
it's taking quite a while for these to
form. You know, this bar took over an
hour to form. This bar took almost an
hour. This next bar took almost an hour.
So, it's, you know, it's easy to look
back at the chart say, "Oh, yeah, we
just we moved like this." But, you know,
when it's when you're sitting in a
bar, not a alcoholic bar, but a price,
you know, a range bar, so to speak, and
it's going nowhere for a long period of
time, you know, you're you sort of in an
area, I don't want to use I don't want
to say consolidation or absorption, but
you're in an area where where people are
happy to trade back and
forth. And, you know, again, a new high
failed divergence. I say failed. didn't
fail till the night session open and we
sold off instead of and didn't get much
of a we did get a bounce but um again
you know we did have that uh the news
for Manchester come out but on the four
range chart again you know today was was
a bit better day for the four range
chart than the than the 10 range and
it's it's easy to look back after the
fact but you know as as a trader you
should pick up you know compare what's
happening in the morning when you come
in to sit down in front of your charts.
What chart should I be looking at?
Should I be looking at a four range? And
to be honest, if if you're coming in in
the morning at, you know, 7:00 and your
range is, you know, 85 12 down to 78 and
a quarter, you know, you're in a very
tight range. So, you know, you should
really be considering, you know, looking
at the four range
chart. If things don't really pick up,
you know, if the market really starts to
move
fast, then you could go to the 10 range
chart. But, you know, if a market's in a
tight range, and for me, you know, five,
seven points is is considered a a
limited range in the S&Ps when you're
coming in by 8 in the morning, that, you
know, it's going to be worth your while
to to look at a four range. So, okay,
you know, here you have the the low of
the day, okay,
S&Ps 78 and a quarter. Now, this
happened at, you know,
4, you know, 440, just before 5:00.
And you know people say do you look at
the night session? Yeah, you have to
look at the night session because you
know lots of times that's where the
highs or lows are made. And in this case
on this day the lows were made here. You
have the divergence. You have the ratio
and you you rallied you know literally
from your low you didn't you didn't come
back down here
um you know at all. Look at that. This
is that's the low there. So, you know,
if if you're not respecting these highs
or lows for the day, um you really
missing out. Or if you don't u you know,
go back and you know, I said, you know,
for some people, I don't know why, you
know, they don't want to consider what
happened in the night session, but you
know, the 30% of the volume on CME
happens between, you know, the reopen
and 7 a.m. So, you know, that's a decent
amount of volume that's traded. But
anyway, you know, you still got a lot of
bullish signals down here. You got the
ratio with the divergence. You got the
delta scupper even giving you a buy
there. And then you start working up,
you know, coming into the cash open
here, making new highs right on the cash
open. Where am I here? So, failed
divergence one at 832, another one 841,
another one 850. So if by now again you
I've talked about this, you know, failed
divergences either, you know, on the way
up is a sign market can go higher.
Failed divergences on the way down. When
they're grouped together, I'm not
saying, you know, one happens at 6:00 in
the morning, another one at 8:00 in the
morning, another one at 12. No. Well,
when they're grouped together, you know,
this market's starting to move 8:32,
8:41, 8:50. You know, every few minutes,
say, you know, every 5, 10 minutes,
you're making a new high and you hit it,
you come off again. And you know that's
a sign that we can go higher here. Then
you know 9007 we hit that high. You come
off. You got three in a row here. 1 2 3.
You don't get the green bar in this one.
But you get the pullback between these
two point of controls which is what you
like. You know where's your stop going
to be? I normally get people asking
where's your stop on the three in a row.
Well look at this point of control here.
Worst case scenario is you know above
the the first
bar. You you just you come back up. You
don't get stopped out. You just go
sideways, get a stack stone in a
balance, you come
off and you know again, you know, if
you're getting short in here, you know,
this is around the 88 and a half
area, you know, 89. I mean, you do trade
down to 86 and a half. I mean, it
depends on on how you want to hold it.
It goes goes down to 5 and a
half, then just sort of bounces around.
Now, you get three in a
row again. Then you get the red bar, you
know, that's the Well, this is the delta
scalper given a cell. Didn't work out.
We stopped out. Get another delta
scalper here. A sell. It didn't work
out. Yeah, you got the price rejector as
well. Now, again, you got the three in a
row. Get the pullback. You don't get the
pullback between the two points of
control that you like. Um, but then you
get the green bar up up up, make new
highs. You got a ratio with a
divergence. It didn't work out. It came
right back with bullish divergence,
bullish divergence. And then this is
important. You got a stacked
imbalance on a retest of a high. And
that's
important. We rally, make new highs. You
get a ratio with a
divergence. You sell off, come back up.
You know, again, you're sort of testing
these highs. You got um point of control
at the top of this bar, point of control
at the top of this bar. So, you know, up
here at at least for now at 90 um 92 and
3/4, there's some volume. Even you see
it here. You test through it, you get
through it again, you come off a little
bit and you know at some point, you
know, you keep hitting that high, this
this area. This is not the high of the
day. It's just below the high. So, you
know, there's some volume and you know,
if the market can get through that, we
can go higher and we do. We got a new
high
here, come off a little bit going into
the close. So, there were some moves,
you know, there weren't the biggest
moves to be had. you
know, day traders, you know, new
traders, they all sort of come into
these things, you know, I say come into
these things, come into trading
thinking, you know, every day they're
going to get 10 point trades
and you just don't. I mean, some days,
you know, you're you're happy to squeeze
a couple drops out of the lemon for your
lemonade and you know, I mean, I get
these emails from people that run
trading rooms. Oh, we had 20 points
today. Oh, we had 10 points, you know,
and I look at the range and I see, you
know, there
was there was a 12-point range on the
day and they're they're claiming they
got, you know, 10 points. But, you know,
that's why I think, you know, traders,
new traders at least, you know, just
come into this market thinking that
every day is going to be big big
movement days where they're going to get
um, you know, 10 points every single
day. You know, sometimes you're not. you
know, sometimes you'll get two points on
a trade, you know, a point here, a point
and a half there. But, you know,
ideally, you'd like to add it up. Now,
it's not to say that those people, you
know, they're claiming to get uh, you
know, 10 points out of a 12point day.
Didn't do that. But, you know, I
consistently see these emails saying,
you know, every single day, you know,
telling me how many points they got. You
I'm a little skeptical of it, but that's
just me. You know, I'm kind of a dick in
that sense, but I'm a skeptical person.
But um you know like I said that that's
myself. Um the Euro
currency. Okay. So this is where we are
right now in the in the evening session.
I mean we did rally a little bit off of
I say off of the news but not by much.
But you know from yesterday in the
currencies you know basically from 10 we
went sideways. You can see here you do
have a delta sculper right there. But
for the most part since 10 pretty tight
range you know 10point range.
But if you you go back, you know, again,
this was interesting. You know, the high
of the day, okay? Well, your first high
of the
day, you had
the ratio with the divergence and you
didn't sell off. You sold off two ticks
and then you rallied right back and
stopped you off. Then you got up to this
new high divergence, but then you got
the delta scalper. So again, it's it's
signaling you in the delta that
something's a foot, you know, that the
market, you know, can be changing. And
then you see lower point of control.
These for me all intents and purposes
equal. These two are equal and we sell
off. Okay. But again, you know, really
up here looking for a sign to be getting
short. I mean, you had a sign earlier.
It didn't work out. you know, maybe you
know, you had price
rejector and honestly I would say, you
know, the prices were rejected there,
but you know, sometimes the market is
still looking for its high and you get
it, you know, a couple bars later up
here and you get the sign up there. Now,
again, yeah, here you had a delta
scalper cell, but it's on a green bar.
So, again, I'm not not interested in
taking it, you know, I just want to show
you guys that so you don't think I'm
trying to cover it up.
Okay. Sorry, I just had a cough right
there. Um, okay. So, next one, last one
I'll talk about. Well, beans, I don't
think anything happened in the beans
that much today. Um, not
really. I'll talk about I'll talk about
crude next. Actually, crude is the one I
want to talk about, but beans, I I
remember not much going on
today. So, where are we? Let me reopen
here. 8:30 you rallied up to the highs.
You hit the
high, you don't have a divergence. You
have a ratio bounds um racial bounds low
there indicating stopping ball. I mean,
you can see 700 contracts traded there.
It's much more than the first time you
traded
777. You don't really ever come back up
there. Excuse me. You hit I'll say the
swing high here, but here you got the
delta scalper giving a sell and you did
sell off a few a few cents.
Excuse me. Um going into this close here
at 950 or close here at 958, but I was
really looking at the close to be
happening somewhere around in here. We
did get this last bump up um in the last
uh few moments of trade, but crude oil
really
quick. Excuse
me. Just when I think I'm getting past
this cold, it keeps coming back. Thought
I got past it and then my kids started
getting it and they passed it back to
me. I got it from them then they gave it
back. But um anyway, so crude oil. Okay,
let's go here from around 6 in the
morning. Delta scalper give a sell here.
Okay, delta surge giving you this buy
here. Open this up so you can see how it
looks. Um get up here to this high.
Nothing in the order flow really. Here
you have a divergence. Okay, again I'm
not convinced just because you got a
divergence, but here you got the
transition. That's this yellow one. And
you got the uh delta scalper also giving
a sell and you sell off. Boom. And it
gets quite aggressive here. Um you know
so you're selling you basically getting
short. You go sideways for the next
couple bars.
5130 5132 you trade all the way down.
New
lows
87. So you know from 30 down into the
90s you know you could have had that
trade quick 40 cents. You get a ratio
with the divergence on the low. You
know, again, that's the signature bread
and butter trade that I look for. Next
bar, if you're getting long, you know,
the 94, 95, 96 area, it trades all the
way up into
teens before it starts coming back down
again. But again, you know, the first
sign, okay, people ask, well, you know,
how do I trail my stop is watch the
points of controls. Once you start stop
having higher points of controls, it's
usually a sign that the market could
start turning on you. So you got point
of control here when the bar you're
getting long next bar is higher than
this bar. Next bar is higher. All a
sudden you get up here and it's changing
right all below and you got a red bar.
That's not a good sign.
Okay. So you know if you're longing here
at 97 95 96 97 you get up here this is a
bearish sign. You should be thinking
about cutting it out once you get down
here to you know 06 07. There's no crime
for cutting it short you know. I mean
what would you rather do? get out here
with a small profit at, you know, 02 or
0405 rather than coming back down to
where you got into the trade and then
take, you know, get out at nothing. You
know, people say, well, you know, I
mean, it can go up. It could bounce and
go back up. But if you're starting to
see negative signs in the order flow,
negative signs against your trade, then,
you know, you get out. Um, here's the
delta surge giving us right into the
low, which I'm not a big fan of taking
those types of trades.
um get up here to the swing high. You do
have a ratio of bonds low. You go from
ratio bonds low to a ratio bonds low. Um
you do rally up here.
Um get
down and here you got the price uh delta
scalper giving a sell here and you just
sort of go
sideways for the next and this is what
time 11:15. um you go sideways, you
know, again, you know, by if you're
looking at this trade and you're in it
here at and it's an hour later and it's
still basically done nothing, you know,
that's your sign to get out. You know,
don't stay in a trade that's going
nowhere. Okay? And you just sort of go
nowhere. And right now in the night
session 9:15, this is where we're
trading. Okay? So, thanks for watching
this video. To learn more about trading
software used in this presentation and
how you can profit from orderflow
trading, visit my website
orderflows.com. And you know, I put a
link in below about the orderflows inner
circle where you get the indicators such
as the price rejector, the delta
scalper, the transition, the U-turn, and
and a few others um as part of the inner
circle. So, you know, if you're
interested in in seeing a lot of these
indicators on your own screen, um you
know, click on that link and you know,
learn more about it. So, thanks
everyone. Bye-bye.